hey everybody can you imagine growing up
in a west pennsylvania coal mining town
without indoor plumbing
running water access to high quality
education
and yet still going on to one of the
most competitive phd programs in the
world at a top ivy league institution
oh by the way that was after you decided
to double major in
folklore and astrophysics at
a certain university in cambridge
massachusetts that begins with the
letter h
you may have heard of it well today's
guest did just that
and she is pre-doctored she'll be doctor
next year
2021 moya mcteer
who is not only a top-notch
astrophysicist
studying how different worlds can exist
around other planets
in parts of our galaxy that are very
different
than our own local neighborhood out here
on the disk of the galaxy
as we inhabit but also she explores the
other worlds that could possibly exist
in terms of science fiction or fantasy
she's in fact a published author
she was an author already before she
started graduate school
and she's working on a book about what
we call
popular science the science of the
galactic
processes that allow planets to form and
that book will be out next year
and that's moya mcteer she's a
young up-and-coming phenom and i can't
wait to see where her career goes
certainly it's already gone out into our
galaxy
and i suspect it'll be going to a galaxy
near you in a very short time
so please sit back enjoy this video
please leave a comment
or a review on itunes or here
on youtube wherever you get this uh this
interview delivered to you so i hope you
really enjoy this
wonderful interview as much as i did
she's really just such a phenomenon to
talk to
played around with a couple of new
technology hacks and trip
tricks and traps uh maybe we had a
little too much
trapping but i hope you enjoy it uh
again leave a comment leave a review on
itunes or wherever you get this podcast
or on youtube
thanks so much enjoy the cosmic voyage
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
welcome everybody it's quite a thrill to
have on my current guest today
moya mcteer who has a very
traditional and very typical background
for astronomers
she grew up in a log cabin in a small
pennsylvania coal mining town
without a conventional toilet or running
water so you know it's just could happen
to all of us it's very typical
she's very conventional very
representative
she's an amazing person super
accomplished and what i love about her
gestalt is that she is not only
a right brain thinker like many of us i
think it's the right brain
i don't know moya can correct me if i'm
wrong i never remember which brain i
have and which one i don't that
probably means i'm one of the friends uh
but moya mcteer uh
was uh was really brought to my
attention because of the work that she
does
uh both inside astronomy inside
fiction writing and uh specifically
science fiction writing which we'll get
to
and uh through the work that she's done
to increase uh diversity and
representation in physics
and so it's a great deal of pleasure
brings me a great deal of pleasure to
welcome
moya here and i just pointed out uh to
my wife that
just through perhaps a cosmic ray
hitting your father or your mother
at just the right time we almost had the
same name brian
i think yeah yes almost
so moya uh is uh as a graduate i think
you're a fifth year or your fifth year
graduate student at columbia
i am yeah fifth and final fifth and
final i love that
and uh we're playing around with a new
setup today so we got different camera
angles there's moya
uh from the left brain side and uh we
got it in the front too uh samoya it's
such a thrill to have you here we're
gonna talk about science we're gonna
talk about your work we're gonna talk
about the galaxy
planets and what it's like to be an
astronomer and i want to talk about your
science fiction novel
that i only had a chance to read a
little bit of but i found it very
engrossing
and i actually want to start with if if
you're woken up in the middle of the
night by some friendly alien
who's come to visit you perhaps back in
your hometown
uh they've come for the coal because all
alien spacecraft will run on coal as i
understand it
um what do you do how do you describe
yourself you do so many different things
what is the material brand that you're
cultivating
yeah so i describe myself as an
astrophysicist
and a folklorist and i try to combine
them as often as possible and i really
do feel like with the two of those
together
i can bring a lot to the table that
sounds so
like self-absorbed but i um i feel like
i can talk to anyone about their
expertise as
an astrophysicist and a folklorist
because i really understand both the
sciences and the humanities and
and what it's like to study both of
those what is folklore what does it mean
to say folklore i know
of course what it means to to tell folk
tales i know about
lore i spend a lot of lore what is
folklore specifically
yeah that's a great question because we
spent so much time
talking about that specifically when i
was studying folklore in college
and it is related to anthropology in
that it's really
looking at the culture of different
people but
it's slightly different from
anthropology and that we are
mostly focused on the stories that
people tell
and sometimes the physical artifacts
that they'll leave behind if those
artifacts
were useful for telling stories or
communicating
which is why as a science communicator i
think being a folklorist is so
helpful because folklore is the stories
that different people tell
so it's myths it's legends it's religion
uh it's
fairy tales it's any sort of pedagogical
uh entertaining story that someone
thousands of years ago would have told
and we're we're still creating
folklore and myths today so some of it
could also be not fictional right i mean
it's
as an anthropological study a lot of it
could be non-fiction correct
yeah we talked about folklore the study
of folklore as a science
when i was in college because it is like
you you
learn these things using the scientific
method you
make hypotheses you look for primary
sources
to test your hypotheses so it's more
observational than it is experimental
because we can't go back in time and
experiment on these different cultures
but
it definitely is done in a
scientifically rigorous way
and what was the inspiration uh to write
your book
i want to know what impelled a graduate
student to write a book
um so the the science fiction book that
i wrote
was in my senior year of undergrad
actually
it was my senior thesis and i had to
write it because i studied both
astrophysics and
folklore in college and i i went to
harvard where you have to
write a thesis that sits at the
intersection of your two fields
it lets the record statement double
major but the american state she just
dropped the h-bomb
the harvard i was wondering i had a bet
how long will it take no no no
uh it's it's actually integral to your
tears to your story because it's part of
your
requirements to graduate with you at a
double major right
yeah and so i usually try not to drop it
but i think it is
uh unusual in that they make you write
this weird
joint thesis and i tried so many
different things i proposed so many
different types of theses
and i i had given up uh until i went to
i think it was probably a double a s
meeting in january i don't remember
which one
and i was sitting at a table at a random
networking lunch and i was talking to
um a professor from rutgers about this
problem i was like i'm trying to do this
weird double major
but no one uh will accept any of the
theses i propose
and he was like well why don't you just
write a science fiction novel
and then i went back to the heads of
both departments and i said
all right what if i write a novel and i
set it
on a real exoplanet that i will research
and
the plot is based on ethnographic
research that i'll do
in hawaii um so it was about the
hawaiian sovereignty movement
and the 30 meter telescope conflict and
they loved it and they let me write it
and then i graduated which was
nice and that's right the uh that's the
the spoiler uh that we should have
alerted that you actually did graduate
despite all odds
um right you think that's something i
can't imagine doing that i had some idea
for a fiction book in
in graduate school i never wrote it
maybe someday i will but what you did is
so
um is is so impressive that you actually
had that i wonder
if after you know next year would you go
back in time and tell
you know the the the moya to not do it
or to do it just seems like it's
such an amazing accomplishment to do it
but it also probably
was a little bit scary and fearful to
write an actual book at such a young age
it was terrifying but it wasn't the
first book that i ever
tried to write i started writing my
first fiction book when i was in middle
school and it was
horrible i i remember it it was about
um two siblings like two sisters
who um you know i
had probably just read uh the chronicles
of narnia and so it was about two
siblings who
for some reason had to go live with an
on on some country estate
and they found that there were magical
worlds behind the walls of this
country home it was absolutely terrible
and i never finished it but i always
wanted to write a book
a fiction book and so when that
professor from rutgers suggested it i
was like yes of course that i
definitely want to do this i didn't get
it published um
but i made it available online for free
and
just the fact that some people have read
words that i've written is really
exciting
even if you know it wasn't published
yeah it's a tremendous accomplishment
and you know it's one of these things
that a lot of people go back later on in
life and then
do publish it with either a traditional
publisher or even self-publishing has
become incredible i mean they found
uh books that are fictional kind of
fantasy books
you know fifty shades of grey for
example i mean that was published uh
self-published uh and then it was come
it came back
it was actually originated from i think
a takeoff on what's the um
what's the vampire uh sci-fi the
uh with kristen stewart uh why am i i
don't know
twilight yeah so i think the woman who
wrote uh fifty shades of grey was like a
writing fan fiction about twilight
online and then all of a sudden she
decided well i could actually
write my own book and she self-published
and then now of course she sold 50
million copies
i actually found i know a friend who
took her book the 50 shades of gray book
and like just rearranged every adjective
and and made it
new so it wasn't exactly plagiarizing
and then they published a self-published
book
under a pseudonym wow it's unbelievable
so don't ever give up the hope that you
could actually publish it there's
it's the accomplishment is in the doing
and the completing
and i want to yeah kind of move towards
the graduate school experience
segue to that now as you see on the
event horizon coming up not too long
from now
graduation um where do you see yourself
going do you see yourself going
in the creative do you see yourself
going academia
or continuing this unique hybrid model
that you are so
uh you know uniquely suited to carry out
i'm definitely going to try and
keep on this unique path i really love
it it's what brings me joy and so i want
to do
science communication full time and
bring in
folklore as often as i can so i'll
continue
um hosting my own podcast i'll continue
giving talks
i'm i'm writing a book a non-fiction
book this time
um i'd like to host a tv show and so
it's going to be a lot of
i guess mostly freelance work but
definitely not
uh in academia strictly do you feel like
the
creative outlets that you have not to
say that science has the
kind of uh pejorative sense that we are
not creative a scientist but do you feel
like as a scientist
you've improved your writing maybe your
critical thinking abilities
from the fact that you've developed this
huge other brain muscle
to mix metaphors yeah absolutely so i
i will say that i think scientists are
some of the most creative people
uh that exist because our
job as scientists is to discover things
that people don't already know and that
requires a lot of creativity but i do
think being a folklorist has helped me
tremendously in both doing science and
communicating it
because i my brand
my specialty in folklore is fictional
world-building
so i i and facts based fictional world
building specifically so i
use different academic disciplines and
combine them together to create
realistic imaginary worlds and that's so
interdisciplinary and it requires so
many different pathways of my brain
connecting where they otherwise probably
wouldn't and so i think that that
that's made my brain so much stronger
than it was five years ago
and so switching to your research uh i
mentioned that i was uh
reading your paper which uh it came out
just in march just as the
pandemic was setting in uh for real and
and monthly notices
and the title of the paper is really uh
you know kind of
provocative in that it really it has
these action items of these
these um traits of what's called copy
writing which is not the same as like
copy editing
it's actually you know there's so called
like i think there's five views that
you're supposed to use like
urgent useful you know basically
actionable
and your your title of this paper is
eight and ten stars in the milky way
bullets experience stellar encounters
within a thousand astronomical units in
a gig year now besides the title of your
autobiographical movie which i'm happy
so walk us through that title and then
this really fascinating research that
you led
this is a first author paper uh and
maybe we'll talk about what that means
to you
how does it compare to writing a book
where you're the only author but first
let's say what is this paper about
and is there any connection in your when
you're writing a paper like this you
actually are thinking about what it
would be like in these planets
undergoing these complex interactions
between the most powerful forces in
nature
um i i love that you thought that that
was a catchy title because i had a
catchy title for it
and then um i think it was something
it was a joke on social distancing my my
advisor
i wanted to put in a joke uh like you
know
bald stars don't social distance or
something like that
um and then emin raz came out the
monthly notices came out with this rule
saying you can't have catchy titles
anymore
and so i decided to just go with like a
very straightforward these are the facts
this is the outcome of the paper um so
what i was doing with this paper was
trying to figure out
how common close stellar encounters are
in the milky way bulge uh i had just
published a paper
about the
ability of a star let me start that over
i had just published a paper about the
relationship between
a star's speed and its ability to host
planets
but only in the solar neighborhood
because i was working with
kepler data which doesn't go very far
out in the galaxy
and i found that there was no
relationship so fast stars are just as
likely as slow stars to have planets
and then i remembered that stuff in the
solar neighborhood moves
pretty slowly and it's pretty boring out
here uh eight kiloparsecs from the
galactic center so i wanted to look in
the milky way bulge
and i simulated the orbits of a million
stars
um over several orbital periods which
for them can range anywhere from you
know
a few thousand years to like a billion
years depending on
what its orbit is like and i found that
80
of them have these close encounters
which
can do so many bad things to the planets
involved it can rip away the planets
from their host stars
it can destabilize the planet's orbits
so that
eventually maybe like a million years
later the planet gets flung out of the
system
and i looked at that
and i was immediately obsessed with
trying to imagine what life would be
like on one of those planets that got
ripped away from its host star
because they exist we've seen rogue
planets out there
in the galaxy these are planets that
don't orbit a host
star so they're just kind of
free-floating out in the galaxy and i
wanted to know
what life would be like on one of those
so that's
just one example of how a finding from
my research
influenced a type of world building
scenario that i wanted to flesh out
i love the art artistry of it i mean
here i'm showing on the shared screen i
don't know if you can see it
some of the images of the orbits and it
really harkened back to like
you know almost like crochet patterns or
something like that but this is actual
simulations of some of the million stars
that you just randomly selected
uh over this million 10 million year
period but it's proof you know that it
makes this you call this an eccentric
rosette orbits
uh characteristic of the galactic bulge
so these patterns would look different
if they were farther out of the galactic
bulge than say the solar system as
absolutely yeah so out here uh the sun
is in
a part of the galaxy called the disk of
the galaxy and you can think of it kind
of like a pancake
it's this really big pancake and all of
the stars like our sun
are blueberries in that pancake and
because it's so
flat it means gravity really only
operates in one way
or for the most part gravity operates in
one way so stars can move on
nice predictable circular orbits but
the bulge is spherical it's
three-dimensional and so
gravity is acting in all of the
different dimensions
and that makes the orbits there so much
more
chaotic and they move on these weird
shapes and at these weird times and it's
a lot harder to predict yeah so i find
it you know just another
kind of manifestation of the fact that
you said you know science
scientists are not only creative but
there's a kind of a stark beauty in
science all its own
in any kind of science i mean we're
partial obviously to astronomy
uh because it is you know the only
science that we can do with the two
telescopes that are built into our
skulls
when we're born but look i mean behind
me is this ball of the milky of the
universe as seen through microwave eyes
that my colleagues and w met made
that's also very beautiful and i've had
people approach me and want to buy it
for you know almost no price am i
willing to sell it uh in front of that
is a klein bottle you know it's a
mathematical entity
and so all these things in math that i
think i want to connect to your
childhood which you've spoken about uh
quite candidly and
and how you're influenced both to
obey the fifth commandment and to
disobey the fifth commandment which is
to honor your mother
and your father so let me take it back
so children are naturally curious
you seem to be exceptionally curious you
grew up in this unique circumstance as i
was teasing about earlier in the
pennsylvania coal mining town which um
uh you know was probably not easy for
you also as a person of color which
we'll get into
but um but specifically what about your
childhood and specifically your mother
encouraged you uh to be a scientist and
then how
did you end up letting her down and come
to not be on speaking terms with your
own mother
oh you you've listened to the whole
thing didn't you um
yeah so my mom when i was growing up was
an adjunct english professor at a local
college
and i actually make more money now as a
grad student than she did
when i was growing up so uh it's
probably pretty obvious that she didn't
want that life for me
and in her mind the best way to
ensure that i didn't have that life was
for me to become a scientist
or an engineer because we thought that
those were the jobs that would make
money
and so she basically groomed me to be a
scientist
i've said that before but she um would
buy me things like microscopes and
chemistry kits
and she encouraged me to go out in the
woods because
i lived in the middle of a forest and so
she we would go on walks through the
forest
and she would point out the different
plants to me and tell me
what they could be used for um we
when we were in the car she would give
me algebra problems but she never called
them algebra problems because that would
sound scary so instead she called them
x questions and i would just have to
solve for x
in my head while we were driving in the
car because when you live in a rural
location you are
driving a lot and so
she really wanted me to be a scientist
and i was one of those annoying kids in
high school who was just so good
at everything that i didn't know what i
wanted to do
and then flash forward i i went to
college i stumbled around a lot
i took a physics class because i thought
maybe i want to do physics
and i had a horrible experience um the
professor
in the class told me during office hours
that i was struggling so much
and i was never going to make it as a
physicist so i finished that class
because it was
after the add drop period like i
couldn't drop the class anymore
but i decided to stop doing science
and then i found folklore i found
folklore mythology because i was
my dorm was across the street from the
falcon myth building
and they gave out tea and cookies and it
was really sweet and
i had always loved reading fiction and
reading about myths
so i decided to study that and my mom
freaked she was like this isn't what i
want for you you're going to have a
horrible life you're never going to make
any money
you realize that as a folklore major
you're going to have to read the bible
right like you don't want to read the
bible and i was like oh
mom like i'm fine and we just got into
this huge fight and then didn't talk for
a couple months
but i was still a like a teenager
in a new city in college i needed my mom
so
i decided to give science another chance
there was some pizza
involved where i signed up for an
astronomy class
specifically because the professor gave
us free pizza
and by the end of the semester i was
kind of hooked
and i didn't want to give either one of
them up so i declared both as a major
and then my mom talked to me again so it
was the condition was you had to at
least have one major in the sciences
right that's that's fantastic
[Music]
so uh yeah many people including you
know myself my mother
was my first you know three-letter
funding agency not the nsf but the mom
you know helping me buy my first
telescope and and that's a critical
thing
and i want to talk to you about that
especially since you are
very much active in both communicating
to young people but also inspiring them
and stoking curiosity in them how do you
make
that of it that you must also
simultaneously
have skills to communicate to the
children
who you want to stoke but also you have
to convince the adults they're the ones
with the checkbooks right so
how have you been able to do that so
successfully is there a model
or is it just innate to who you are
specifically
um well usually i don't do a lot of work
with kids
i usually focus on on the adults because
i want
to help them become more critical
thinkers so they can
mostly vote and make better voting
decisions but also so that
you know if they have kids they
recognize the importance of
giving their children a introduction
to stem not necessarily with the goal of
making their kids scientists because we
need artists and um other like we don't
we don't want a world where everyone is
a scientist but i think everyone should
know how to think like one at least um
but i think when i am speaking to kids
and i
do a lot of events where the audience is
families so it's adults and their
children i think just being human
being not being afraid to let my
personality through
is is really helpful because it's one of
the most intimidating things about
science is that scientists
feel robotic and unapproachable
that's how we've been represented in the
media for so long and
seeing a real living example of a human
who does science helps a lot i don't
think it's because of who i
am i think anyone who can talk about
science
as their like fully expressed individual
self is going to
grab people's attention so i spoke to
jen 11 who's uh
a professor at barnard that you might
have not gotten to know
in uh up city new york no uptown new
york
um and i and i had a conversation with
her on the podcast in
in the spring and i actually said
something provocative
you know and i want to get your take on
it too which is that you know should we
not require
scientists since we are paid mostly by
the public and taxpayer money
should we not require like shouldn't
everybody be able to be a moya mateer
like in other words
didn't they spend some amount of time
exercising whatever that brain i keep
forgetting which side it is but
whatever side the left brain is is
supposed to be logical and the right
side is supposed to be creative but i
feel like they've
uh rolled that back yeah and found that
that's not true
yeah it's something about like politics
left and right but we're not going to
get into that
because this show is apolitical um but
uh but you're right i'll probably forget
that
that factoid you just told me before the
end of the podcast but what do you think
about requiring i mean i studied quantum
mechanics you study
you know stellar dynamics radiative
processes
uh that's required you cannot graduate
from a top
university like columbia and call
yourself a phd
uh in astrophysics without it but why do
we say uh
communication that's a soft skill like
um you know we don't you don't need to
do that
yeah that's a great question and i'm
split
on it honestly because i i do think that
the most important part of the
scientific process is communicating what
you've learned
but at the same time i also know that
everyone
has their own penchants for skills
not everyone's going to be comfortable
with public communication
and i don't think we should force people
to do something that's so outside of
their comfort zone
and so that's why i think we should have
more
collaboration between people who are
very hardcore
science i do the research i don't
necessarily feel comfortable telling
people about it
and i'm not super skilled in telling
people about it and
um people like me who are very
comfortable talking about
it and honestly i'm not the i'm not the
best researcher
out there like i do cool science but i'm
not the the most
uh passionate about astrophysics and so
i think that if we can get more
collaboration between those types of
people
that would be an awesome system i guess
just to push back i don't usually push
back at my guests but
you can handle yourself so to push back
you know jana said something
which you know at least in the
experience she had she she said you know
not only would
uh colombia and barnard not like give
her
special dispensation to write a
fictional book
about uh alan turing and uh kurt gertle
but uh but they they almost intimated
that they would she'd be punished in a
sense
uh for doing it you know where i am uh
it wasn't so much of a threat but it was
like
the best you can hope for is you won't
be punished in other words
um so just to push back a little bit
like it wasn't easy for you to learn
orbital celestial mechanics um why
should somebody who's not good at
communicating just oh
let's give him her you know him or her
free pass
it's not really what they're supposed to
do you know they can be they don't have
to be
i actually find the soft skills are
paradoxically much more i use
communication
i use presentation i use persuasion and
what you do so well
um and it's almost pretty natural in
your case is this storytelling if you
can tell a story
you have a career no matter what your
field is even in astronomy so why take
it easy on our colleagues
you know the old joke of you know how do
you know a scientist is outgoing because
he looks at your shoes when he talks to
you instead of his own
um why do we give it why do we give our
fellow colleagues you know a pass why
don't we say look
you just you studied quantum mechanics
you got to study uh you know how to read
a room and how to deliver a speech
yeah and this is something we've talked
about at columbia actually within the
astronomy department we've had
a lot of conversations in the last year
or so about
restructuring the program and one of the
the suggestions was having almost two
tracks of the phd
one for people who know for sure they
want to stay in academia it's their
life's dream to become
a research professor uh and so they will
do like the pure research stuff and then
another track for people who
want to go into industry or want to go
into science communication and
they want to learn the skills of doing
scientific research
but uh they don't want to completely
ignore
the the soft skills they're usually
called and
i think that that might be a way forward
um
yeah i totally agree with you it's it's
not fair to expect
the the more right-brained people uh
to learn the the left brain stuff and
and not
you know the other way around right but
because i almost feel like you know when
i've heard it said
you know you'll say something to
somebody about something scientific
and they'll say oh don't ask me that i'm
not a math guy
but you never have someone say uh don't
ask me to like spell a word or use
proper grammar i'm not an english guy
you know it's like
we tend to like uh hold scientists and
this touches back to what you said and
i've had this conversation
on the podcast with professor jim gates
who's the
president-elect of the american physical
society and he said you know one of the
most pernicious
you know myths about scientists is that
they aren't you know human and that they
can only be a scientist if you're like
einstein and he says einstein wasn't
always einstein you know
uh he he had his share of uh peccadillos
failings
blunders if you will and so you know by
holding scientists to this you know oh
it's okay you just stay in your lane
i think i think we could do better
because ultimately
if the public you know ever loses trust
in science and that's our next topic
um i think it'll be extremely
detrimental not just for science
certainly for science but also for
society
as a whole so moving to that um one of
your taglines is that you want to help
people
trust science and help scientists tell
good stories so
the first part kind of intrigued me and
i wanted to again you know very
uh provocatively kind of tweak you in a
sense because
you tell these wonderful fictional
stories which by definition are not true
how does does that run the risk of
undermining
you know actual science i was here like
can't we just build a freaking wormhole
and like take the garbage to the sun
like are there is there a danger of
fiction
being more almost more influential than
science
fact yes
absolutely we see it happening right now
uh where people are either intentionally
because they're malicious horrible
people or um
because they just don't have the right
information they're spreading out
these lies about science you know things
like uh whether or not
masks work or how far apart you should
be when you're social distancing and i
can only think of covet examples right
now because that's
the life i'm what else what else is
there yeah
um it's what we're steeped in but uh
people spread lies about science all the
time and those lies are often more
believable
than the fact because they're they're
easier to digest
or they're more convenient or they're
what people actually want to believe
and so yeah uh fiction
when it's presented in a persuasive way
is so dangerous
um and that's why
that's that's mostly part of why i want
to be a science communicator
it's why i want to tell people the facts
in
engaging and persuasive ways hopefully
so that i can rise above
that noise of all of the the persuasive
lies
yeah you've come up with an innovative
title for that which you call
facts based world building first of all
moya can you tell us what does it mean
to world build
i've only written non-fiction um but can
you tell what does it mean to world
build and then
how do you differentiate science-based
fact-based world building from
ordinary word world building
so world building is something that's
pretty common in a
genre that is called speculative fiction
and
fantasy and science fiction are both
underneath that
spec thick umbrella but there are other
genres in there too
uh and so world building is the process
of creating
uh imagining a new world
to set your story in and and it
involves everything from creating an
entire uh
literary history to your world to
creating entirely new
biological species to inhabit your world
and and everything in between
um and so world building is so fun neil
gaiman my favorite author
calls world building the the art of
getting to play god
which is awesome you get to play god and
you don't have any of their
responsibilities
and i talk specifically about
facts-based world building because i
know that different people
have their own processes um i i follow
one person on twitter who writes fiction
and she
makes her world-building decisions by
doing tarot card
readings so whenever she has to make a
decision about what to include in her
world she
she draws a tarot card and is inspired
in that way and
i am inspired by hard reading this year
i'm teaching quantum mechanics
so very fast are you really no no no i
thought crazier i thought
poetry for physicists i did teach that
class nice yeah
yeah yeah so building how does that
couple in yeah um so i
draw my inspiration from different
academic disciplines and i do it in a
in the same order every single time i
always start by
imagining what the environment is uh
and then i start thinking about the
biology which depends
directly on the environment and also a
lot of randomness
um so i do environment then biology and
then culture
and then i can go back and figure out
how all three of those things have
influenced each other
and so there's a bit of a cycle going on
but um
i i like to actually talk to experts in
other fields
when i was writing my my senior
thesis that science fiction novel i
talked to
my friends who were biology majors and
psych majors uh
and engineering majors and uh that
really helped me make the world feel
as realistic as it possibly could
given the the constraints of both what
the story was
and what my skills at the time were so
if you're advising a young
student both as a graduate student in
astronomy or say
you know a mini moya comes along who has
both of these attributes
what would you say to him or her to um
to
you know kind of the the words of wisdom
to your younger self so to speak
uh to capitalize on these strengths
assuming they have the ability to do
both
um how would you advise them uh to
actually
have a schedule have a workflow how
would you do it
um like the logistics of everything yeah
that's something i'm still trying to
figure out
to be quite honest all right um our
follow-up podcast
we'll have that after you get the day
after you defend
right no i i think part of it is just
being willing to set boundaries
when i started grad school i knew i
wanted to do a lot of
science communication and that has grown
significantly over the last five years
but
i was always very clear that i was going
to give talks and i
wasn't going to spend 100 of my time on
research so
um setting boundaries and knowing what
your priorities are
um i think that that's so valuable and
it's helped
me uh carve out the time i need to do my
cycom
and you mentioned neil gaiman anyone
else in the fictional space that's an
influence
and or anybody you would like to promote
and then do you have corresponding
influences in science
um i'm not sure about promotion because
all of the the people that i read are
are so famous they're doing just fine
but i i love neil gaiman for his world
building
i love tamora pierce i read a lot of
tamora pierce when i was younger she
writes
such strong uh female characters
and is able to weave together the
different universes and like time
periods um she she wrote several
different series
all of which were set in the same
universe but at different times
um and i think that's really hard to do
and i
really love lainey taylor for her
writing style i think she has some of
the most beautiful pros i've ever
written
and she's really good at um surprise
genre bending i would recommend reading
the
strange the dreamer duology so the first
book is called strange the dreamer the
second book is called muse of nightmares
uh and and it's the first book feels
very fantasy-ish and then the second
book is like
surprise we're more sci-fi now um
i could talk about books in fiction
forever
um so yeah i have a lot of idols there
yeah oh very good yeah uh so i'm showing
on the shared screen you not only
you know kind of discuss this on your
podcast but you also have these
worksheets which are so wonderful
um try to look through them and they're
ways to like start the creative juices
flowing
uh and this is specific to the type of
you know culture
the environment the characters etc that
you talked about
i think that's i want to thank you for
this because so and i'll conclude these
in the show notes um
that i email out to that to the audience
later on
yeah it's really wonderful and i just
love seeing you know creative uh people
just do their magic turn them loose give
them what they need to serve
to succeed and i want to turn now to
another dimension
um that i think you're um will have an
important perspective on
and that's diversity equity and
inclusion in stem
so you've spoken about some of your
experiences as a person of color
in science and academia first of all i
want to know is there
is there also a challenge for that in
the in the science fiction
science fantasy you know kind of uh
model universe
are these things happening is there a
reckoning occurring in that community as
well absolutely
i mean if you think of the top science
fiction
names you're probably going to think of
isaac asimov
or arthur c clarke maybe you'll think
octavia butler and ursula k leguin but
like
you'd have to those are for the most for
the for the biggest swap of the
population those are like deep cuts you
know
um and so we we are having a reckoning
where people are trying to promote more
diversity in fiction and in publishing
and in game design
wizards of the coast just had a lot of
bad publicity because of the way they
were treating
uh freelancers who were people of color
um
i've seen on twitter a lot of editors
and who work at publishing houses
specifically requesting
submissions from uh writers and
of color and and women and people who
have been traditionally left out of
these industries
so yeah people are trying their hardest
to to make things more equitable
when you um think about this i had a
conversation with dr
dr becky smetherst um from the uk who
runs a very popular youtube channel
this week and you know we almost were
talking about the extra burden
in her case uh she's uh she's uh
obviously a white woman
but she was even saying you know there's
almost like this external tax that
people who are mine underrepresented
minorities in science have to pay
and certainly you know according to a
so-called intersectional theory you know
kind of the more of these
different classes that you have to
navigate it becomes even harder
i mean is there uh is there in your
opinion is there this extra burden i
know i've talked to my friends
um ranging from you know jim gates to
stephon alexander the current president
of the national society of black
physicist uh do you feel like there is
an extra burden on you as a person of
color as a woman of color
uh in this field um that is actually
you know not something you signed up for
yes um in so many different ways
i guess the two that come to mind
immediately are
mentoring and and a lot of emotional
labor that i get asked
to do as a woman of color and as a black
woman
so at any given time i'm mentoring
a handful of younger students who are
looking for role models in the field
that look like them and
have similar experiences and because
there are so few of us in the field
right now
there are fewer than a hundred black
women with phds in
any physics related field so because
there are so few of us
we have to do more of the mentoring work
than uh our colleagues do
and then the other thing that comes to
mind is a phenomenon called stereotype
threat
which is the psychological thing that
happens uh it affects you when you
are under when you're being examined so
if you're taking a test
um academic or if you're taking
something like a driver's test
um when you are reminded of negative
stereotypes that your different
identities have associated with them
you perform worse on those tasks so um
women are stereotypically perceived to
be worse drivers and so when women are
reminded
of their uh their gender before
a driving exam they perform worse
they've
done really amazing studies uh trying to
carve out or like separate the the
different
stereotypes associated with identities
and so i remember reading about this one
experiment what that they did with
asian women um so asians are
stereotypically good at math women are
stereotypically bad at math
and so they um did this experiment where
they separated
people taking this test and they told
one group they reminded one group of
asian women about their like asian
identity and they performed really well
on the test and then they performed
another group
of asian women about their gender
identity and they performed worst on the
test so
um stereotype threat is just something
that's constantly in the back of your
mind because you feel like
you have to be a representative of your
entire identity group and that just puts
so much pressure on you and it takes up
a lot of head space
yeah yeah i almost feel like it's a tax
and and it's unfair it's asymmetric and
then
it's it's coupled with uh you know
something that is also pernicious was
just feelings of guilt
and uh regret you know if you don't uh
supervise this one young
you know african-american girls and you
know
who you know you must get that a lot and
and you can't say yes i mean either the
power of saying no
allows you to say yes to so many other
opportunities and and you've had an
amazing amazing accomplishment a
series of accomplishments already um and
so you know it just
um and so i just doing the world
building thought experiment
which is what i think of a lot of
science fiction is so good at you know
thinking about experiments that can't be
done but like
i was just like how many books would she
have written if she was a white man
but uh yeah that was uh just you know
because not because you couldn't do it
but because you're so
uh spread uh to so many different
directions and you have so many
allegiances but
you know one thing i do want to commend
you on is is that never in all the
research that i've done
do i catch you saying like oh like woe
is me like
in fact it's almost the opposite like
you have this irrepressible desire just
you're just going to succeed and win no
matter what
well it's because you don't see all the
crime behind the scenes
i'm there for you if you ever need a
zoom shoulder to cry on
um so we only have a few minutes left uh
but i want to uh ask you a couple of
rapid fire questions
and uh the first one is uh pulitzer or
nobel prize which would you prefer
oh pulitzer okay great
um next question is a question that i
ask all my guests
and that is um uh you know you're gonna
live to be 120 years old we hope uh
maybe even longer if uh you know certain
certain advances can be made uh
including one of my kids is working on
the never dying pill
so i'll let you know when that comes out
uh that's pretty please do
but in the future i want to ask you what
would you put in a will
in sort of a document that summarizes
what you've learned in terms of wisdom
in terms of
ethics in terms of the way to behave not
material will but what would you like to
give over to
uh to you know people in the future uh
about you
in terms of your wisdom and what you've
accumulated so far ethically and morally
on earth
well i've only had like 25 years to gain
this wisdom so there's not much in the
bank
but i i think one thing i would want to
make sure people
know is that myths are humankind's
earliest version of science
and that being
an individual and like expressing your
expressing yourself doesn't necessarily
mean that you're
not that you don't care about the common
good or the community
i think when we when we talk about
individualism versus
a community oriented or a group oriented
identity we put them at odds and they
don't have to be like you can you can be
your unapologetic self and still care
about the good of the group
and you should yes exactly that's the
imperative aspect of it
uh next what object if you've ever seen
the movie 2001 a space odyssey as i
might assume that you have have you seen
it no
oh okay well i i'm sorry i've only seen
that you know people ask me what you
think about
i was actually asked by like a border
guard once when i was coming into the
united states
you know like oh you say you're an
astrophysicist you know like what'd you
think of interstellar
i'm like uh i hadn't seen it and i was
just like well the wormhole has certain
quantum dynamical properties and the guy
was just like all right forget it you're
you can go through you're welcome um but
there's a scene in that uh where
uh these these first these
australopithecine kind of creatures come
upon this monolith
this vast structure that has some
seemingly no
purpose to them and they kind of like
try to pit it with with their bones or
something
and then later on these monoliths occur
like one's on the surface of the moon
and they're meant to be like time
capsules for the future that summarize
this ancient civilization that no longer
exists that's kind of guiding humanity
so to speak but i want to ask you if you
had a monolith a time capsule
that's going to last for a billion years
what fact what
detail what data would you want to put
in it like what is the most
impressive or important thing that
you've discovered and that you want
the universe to know about
i don't think there's anything i've done
that that's that's that important or
special
but i having talked to enough
anthropologists and archaeologists i
know
one issue that we run into so often
is uh people don't write down their
their daily stuff
and so uh a billion years from now if
there are still
living creatures um no one today will
have like they just won't have the
information about what our daily lives
are like
and so i feel like the best way to get
that across is
my my netflix list okay
like my um because i couldn't put it on
a cd rom moya come on you got to put it
on a cd rom
it's gotta last ability a lot i watch a
lot of tv we're gonna need some
high-tech
uh data compression to get all the stuff
that i watch
um but i think watching something like
uh netflix's the circle which is all
about social media use and social media
experiments
um but also things like new girl which
show
just like the average life of a very
weird group of people but you get a
sense for what life is like in
um you know early 2010s l.a and i think
that
that is really valuable information to
take to the future great okay moya well
the last couple of things just involve
the plug zone you you're familiar with
the habitable zone but now i want to
plug you
and i want you to plug uh things in
addition to your
social media presence which is only a
force for good
uh it could be found at go astro mo on
twitter
uh you have a podcast called the
exo-lore podcast am i pronouncing that
right
okay great and i just followed you so
now you got 135 followers there
and uh 10 300 400 on
on your main channel um and you have all
these wonderful worksheets people can
get in touch with you you have a patreon
page which we'll link to
you do so much you give away so much
amazing content it's really been
fascinating
uh to kind of do a deep dive into the
multiverse of moya
and learn more about you is there
anything i didn't ask you that you'd be
eager to talk about in the last couple
of minutes
i'm writing a book right now a
non-fiction book about
the history and evolution of the milky
way
but i'm bringing in a little fictional
twist i'm telling it from the galaxy's
perspective like it's writing its own
autobiography
ah cool well i hope that's out i can uh
have you back on the podcast and we can
promote that
and uh any any other uh chances that we
can have to interact
i would be just delighted uh maya mcteer
soon to be
pre-doctor uh in less than a year next
time we talk perhaps
you will be a phd but i think you've
already accomplished enough for multiple
phds
uh everything you do i want to thank you
so much for being on the into the
impossible podcast
thanks for having me this has been a
great time
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences
at the university of california san
diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco
you